five
nice back three
another thing that might come into play
here oh
wow wow he charged backdash to bait the
reaction and then run and can can four
willing to take these risks
but i feel like akilah is constantly
finding us back to the wall yeah
wow the side step
side step out of mistrust into aop into
the whiff punish
the raid down no throw rich awesome it's
okay
you fell on the mat so it doesn't hurt
that much three let me come back here
you got 12 seconds betted on the los
angeles didn't get launched for it
though he potentially could still come
back that stop there's a grip here's the
slide
he's going to bake the top
you win i'm gonna stop calling it the
ribbon i'm gonna start calling it the
skywalker
two
try to fuzzy duck it so i think this
time you're just like you know what i'm
gonna let it rip or it might get might
be pissed about getting hit by the
oscars there's low parry here but
there's only nine seconds left gets the
reset into the damage here
each floor punch is one second just back
dash away
one
that can be trickier than people think
it is
yeah it's so slow we saw skywalker duck
and then get back up and got hit
he's just the hell
moon catapult over oh my god the dt
eastern instant slide mix up
he is so pissed he got hit with that up
four that was all out of anger
[Music]
[Music]
you